welcome to this video well let's play
sicilian delenn crack my arm from the US
yeah the Kalashnikov got the always
intended to to study this a bit a bit
more detail and I always firm really
forgot forgot to do it and what was the
right smooth order here forgot it it
should be six or something right that
cannot be totally bad something like
that my it's probably not the most
precise there should be seven many men
them I don't know okay but this is some
very em slow type of specially called
for set up with 93 and this is normally
not too dangerous for black white can it
best count on a a very slight edge the
reason why all this is playable of
course is that the time spent on night
be 5 a 3 C 4 III it's just very very
long-winded maneuvering and it's not
like em white has made nem revolutionary
great progress in the meantime Leiter
has just gone to e3 so what now I can I
can think about 90 form it's not totally
crazy
yeah why do you probably put something
on d5 I can also play like this Queen d7
something to the five and Bishop the aid
it's not one think about how to continue
i can i can even take him it's not it's
not bad yeah interesting let's try that
it's a bit unusual for this kind of
structure but the thing is I've got the
bishop on d 8 and this means i can put
it here very uncommon but not bad or in
the bishop cannot be bad on physics
really ah ok so what now hmm yeah snide
f5 an idea or as Bishop h3 no I can take
III the 73d one night f5 Bishop age 393
Bishop e7 night XD one Bishop c8 I have
Bishop f2 yeah can do weird
can also play this first provoking rupee
one yeah maybe it's not bad and now
think about this a bit more it also be
five it's not bad hmm
yeah but I'd like to exchange them
exchange the night cm maybe I'm I'm okay
it's not really trying for more than
being slightly worse which this position
is probably the bishop is potentially is
the best the worst piece here I have
chances to get ok mum yeah just just go
into the good end game I don't mind so I
have a locator on the dark squares I can
get the night to see 5 and a ver have a
good night against bad bishop and gave
me the bishop is not terribly bad but it
is bad with all the pawns being on light
squares yeah this is one reason why it
is not terribly bad it's just bad you
can activate it a little bit but black
is still far more comfortable
I'm intending you for no
so now should I go a four or not yeah I
guess I should it's a good I think a
good moment you cannot really take it I
will get c 4 and a 4 so let's go here
now I can't even undermine this further
on f4 I can also play you for everything
else fails so now let's sign let's see
how to play this yeah this is probably
the way to go to go to a to activating
the rook I want 97 to c5 of course this
would help me enormously yeah so what
now
hmm yeah i'm not sure but okay if he
takes i have an ID for this is actually
important so i can play this first I can
always play you for anyway if I don't
have a better idea maybe King f it would
have been better know that I think of it
now okay yeah you know I can cover
bishop age 3 is out of the picture the
main issue is the time here anyway spent
down as usual too much time
ya know just get the rooks off and it's
it's done but easier easier said than
done with the rooks off I have a really
nice endgame check check oh this is nice
one pair of brooks exchanged and he's
got no way to invade in my position b3
is also covered by the night I'm just
intending look here let's try to keep
this attacked King f65 invading now he's
caught up with the time this is
reassuring
not sure that it's enough rugby three
could be but it's not I'm not sure ok
let's um reroute him so that Knight g4
is an additional idea time morning check
check yeah probably place is far too
complicated check check white forfeits
on young long time hmm yeah the sea porn
is now very dangerous but ok and the
computer says I'm just winning with the
95 next ok yeah I didn't really find
find an ID a phone hmm naughty for him
Nate a4 to be too yeah this is what I
didn't see I thought this of course and
no I didn't see a movie I can go here
this is strong I'm just threatening to
take and he's he's really out of moves
rooks III that's 91 and if I win the c-4
porn is just not just a pawn I mean I'm
dominating him with a king anyway so
nothing moves it is not helping like
this I can I can just take this this is
the threat and d5 is hanging so yeah ok
then there must have been a win he he
drifted into this passive position from
position where there was not much going
on really here for example he's got a
good move for Charles overlooked c5 this
means that regard to also was bad yeah
this was this was the right one I just
saw it too late threatening to take and
after the capture I've got I've got this
coming and again I'm better here with
the great night and the the bed the bed
pawns in relation to them to the bishop
yeah here he have the c5 was good i take
group takes and okay why does not but
not worse at all began their c5 but he
didn't do it and now after this I'm
better I'm very much better now because
I got this eternal night on c5 against
the this is the bishop that is pointing
into thin air yeah the pre instructive
middlegame endgame here and now it's
it's a one-way street especially after
Luke's wife this is this is very nice
now because he's got no counter play at
all he can never invade here with just
one look got it all covered cannot go to
be three and I've got the active rook
alright thanks for watching